es uno de los 26 millones de matrimonios
que se celebrarán este año en eeuu
como frank y lay lina muchas parejas
tuvieron que posponer sus celebraciones
por la pandemia y ahora se dan el sí
quiero por todo lo alto
[Aplausos]
la lista de invitados es mucho más larga
y no se escatima en gastos para que el
día sea perfecto
el país está viviendo una avalancha de
bodas que ha desbordado a toda la
industria
está fuera de control en este momento
pasamos de las cancelaciones masivas por
el quabit a las reservas masivas en el
último mes es sorprendente está
desbordando nuestras capacidades
ashley el cual lleva 30 años trabajando
en eventos él y su equipo están
preparados para la temporada pero
reconoce que con tantas bodas al mismo
tiempo es complicado encontrar
inventario para todas pensando este
ánimo dos millones estamos entendiendo
cuál es la normalidad todo al último
minuto pero toda la industria debe
unirse y ayudarse mutuamente estas
flores han tenido que reservarlas con un
año de antelación
encontraron dj tampoco fue fácil sí
estoy muy ocupado es abrumador espacios
como éste tienen toda la agenda del 2022
completa y si antes sólo se celebraban
bodas los fines de semana ahora también
se festeja de lunes a viernes y a
cualquier hora del día
[Música]
por eso tampoco hay descanso para los
wedding planner como billón
utilizando
al reto de conseguir los deseos de los
novios ahora se une saber encontrar las
mejores alternativas disponibles
nada nada tan moderno pero no quiero
lucir aún a mi madre o la princesa diana
será una tarea que no es fácil cuando
cada vez hay menos inventario picasso
son iguales
dado que hay tantas bodas los
inventarios no son suficientes incluso
si necesitamos flores y se está
acaparando todo por eso kitty acabó
contratando los servicios de este
wedding planner para poder casarse en el
2022 eso sí ha tenido que conformarse
con ir al altar un viernes por la mañana
viernes o una fecha en noviembre nos
casaremos el viernes no hay problema es
perfecto
la demanda es tan alta que las parejas
ya están preparando las bodas del 2023
bueno el don de las bodas empezó tan
pronto se levantaron las restricciones y
tuvimos un aumento en el 2021 pero en el
2022 es como si todo el mundo se
quisiera casar
es por eso ocurre esto tengo una llamada
con teléfono no descansa nunca
tampoco está siendo fácil encontrar un
vestido de novia los diseñadores hacen
horas extra para llegar a tiempo
pero a pesar de las dificultades
nada impide que al final la magia de
este día
ya
cumpla todos los deseos
y los novios pueden subir al altar para
prometerse amor eterno sin
preocupaciones